c'est vraiment le buzz du moment alors
justement je me suis posé la question
est-ce qu'ils avaient sorti ressorti ce
livre pour faire un buzz parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un énorme buzz c'est un
des livres les plus le livre le plus
terrible de l'histoire
mein kampf le livre d'hitler qui a été à
la base de son programme et du cauchemar
de la seconde guerre mondiale qu on
pourra maintenant tous lire puisqu'il ya
une reddition aux éditions fayard une
grande maison d'édition fayard et si
aujourd'hui que fayard publie sa
réédition de mein kampf dans une version
critique attention avec des commentaires
de nombreux spécialistes d'une analyse
c'est la première fois qu'un éditeur
publie l'ouvragé passé dans le domaine
public en 2016
on va en parler ce soir parce que c'est
vrai que ça défrayé la chronique
hier j'ai vu que beaucoup de unes de
magazine était consacré à la réédition
de ce livre on avec noir nos klarsfeld
merci d'être avec nous merci et arnaud
vous êtes pour la publication vous nous
expliquer pourquoi dans un instant et il
ya les psys corbières député est
professeur d'histoire alexis 1 c'est ça
que j'aime le faire d'abord un petit
tour de piste et après j'aimerais avoir
bien sûr les avis d'arnaud et et
d'alexis vous j'en ai marre vous êtes
pour
si on veut acheter mein kampf
aujourd'hui c'est possible c'est édité
par les éditions latines et s'est vendu
il ya cent mille exemplaires qui sont
vendues par an donc là au moins je
trouve que fayard a le mérite de faire
une sorte d'édition contextualiser
expliqué évidemment même critique et
qu'un mot qui est à dire qu'il n'est pas
adapté
mais moi je pense qu'il faut absolument
pas effacer l'histoire il faut pas quand
céline histoire ce qui vient des états
unis
il faut expliquer il faut mettre en
perspective il faut comprendre d'où
vient l'erreur
comment alors comment comment elle a pu
advenir en plus c'est très bien fait il
ya des autres il ya une introduction qui
est très très longue c'est deux tiers du
de cet ouvrage
ça n'est pas mein kampf donc c'est très
bien fait il ya des historiens avec des
pop up très précis pour déconstruire la
pensée de d'hitler voilà donc je pense
que c'est très utile et à une époque
aujourd'hui on veut tout effacé je pense
que justement il faut donner du sens à à
l'époque voilà en fait c'est pas pour le
grand public un parce que c'est en
édition limitée le livre coûte sans
trouble je crois est vraiment partout il
faut le commander
après il précise bien un prénom eu une
nouvelle traduction annotations critique
analyse historique vers 2 ou penser
malgré cela c'est un nom je suis
totalement contre
alors bien sûr ce n'est pas une
opération commerciale parce qu'en plus
les bénéfices seront reversés à la
fondation que je suis bien c'est très
bien les éditions fayard le dire parce
que il y en a plein qui savaient pas ça
absolument nous c'est une opération
commerciale c'est une narration voilà
deux nouveaux outils de communication
mais malgré tout ça me semble
inapproprié surtout dans la france
d'aujourd'hui cette france fracture et
qui a besoin de créer ça va activer pour
moi ça va activement des haines des gens
vont s'en inspirer des gens à la courte
penser ils vont innovantes des mots
d'historiens ils vont prendre ça au
premier degré vont s'en servir comme
d'une sorte de bréviaire
je trouve que c'est un produit
inflammable très dangereux je suis
totalement contre 7 et 10 alors arnaud
classe à 12 dans deux points de vue
complètement différent vous vous c'est
quoi votre position n'est ce pas que
madame a très bien expliqué là les
prémices si vous si on vous ouvre par
exemple le livre n'importe où on voit
que hitler le texte dit l'air est ici et
là il ya le bouclier protecteur des
annotations qui permettent d'expliquer
alors on dit dans des temps pareil mais
dans des temps pareil on est en temps de
semis crise et dans des temps de semis
crise apparaissent des démagogues qui
sont des démagogues à la fois d'extrême
droite et d'extrême gauche et on doit se
prémunir contre les démagogues et la
meilleure façon de se prémunir contre
les démagogues c'est d'étudier le texte
du plus grand démagogue du du xxème
siècle qui a conduit à des catastrophes
et vous êtes une émission je suis venu
vraiment parce que les jeunes regardent
votre émission
et si j'ai un message à faire passer aux
jeunes c'est celui-là on retourne et
vous sur l'histoire du 20e siècle et
regardez à quoi ont conduit les régimes
d'extrême droite les régimes d'extrême
droite ont conduit à auschwitz et les
régimes d'extrême gauche ont conduit au
goulag
alors je vous en prie mesdames et
messieurs les jeunes c'est à dire
développer votre esprit critique et 7 et
7 ce livre qui est destiné
essentiellement aux chercheurs permet de
développer l'esprit critique de voir en
quoi les démagogues
on est maître des fosses des fausses
informations hitler dit par exemple
j'étais en permission en 1916 jeu
survenu à berlin à berlin il n'y avait
que des juifs à l'arrière il n'y avait
pas de juifs au front alors que le
pourcentage de juifs rose au front était
très élevé par rapport à la population
de juifs en général en allemagne et
d'ailleurs c'était la même chose en
france les juifs étaient se sont battus
tant en allemagne qu'en france mais
c'est très important que il y ait un
esprit critique qui se former l'esprit
critique ne peut se former qu en
étudiant le mal et en le décortiquant et
c'est destiné aux chercheurs on l'a
rappelé c'est il faut le commander c'est
pas la photo de hitler qui est là et
encore je reviens sur ce comédien gilles
verdez hitler on le voit partout sur
toutes les chaînes toutes les chaînes et
d'histoire quand vous regardez comme
nous l'expliquent c'est à vous regarder
quand on voit iter c'est douala et dans
des positions qui sont des positions
avantageuses
le bras levé devant des milliers de
supporters comme un public en un forum
romain avec tous les bons là et au moins
il est expliqué les bénéfices sont
versés
c'est mon père qui a obtenu sa la
fondation auschwitz birkenau
les deux historiens qui ont fait le
travail qu'il faut citer florent
braillard grande rev andréas virgin qui
était également ont fait un travail
remarquable
ce livre ne peut faire que du bien parce
que par les cliques marquis il est lui
c'est à dire les universitaires et les
professeurs qui vont véhiculer l'esprit
critique à l'heure à leurs élèves alors
alexis vous êtes professeur d'histoire
aussi alexis corbière un pas seulement
députés et pour vous êtes contre la
publication de cet ouvrage vous même
avec les annotations critique ouais
c'est à dire que j'ai entendu les
arguments
le but paraît-il c'est pour lutter
contre l'extrême droite faudrait faire
lire ce livre c'est raté à 100 euros
c'est la face adressé à tout le monde
ces extraits ou même sabot je vais y
revenir si vous voulez mais pour lutter
contre le nazisme il faudrait faire lire
ce livre est quand même si vous voulez
pour l'ex sur l'extrême gauche je trouve
ça bizarre de votre part comitis inégaux
entre les choses mais pour lutter contre
les totalitarismes se classent fait
contredire ceux liés à 100 euros c'est
une élite qui va se le payer donc c'est
raté donc pour soi alors vous considérez
que soit vous considérez que c'est que
les plus riches qui peuvent se payer
l'antidote contre les totalitarismes
ou alors faut faire un travail populaire
donc cet argument il ne tient par le
travail et leurs effets par les éleveurs
les universitaires et les alors les
posément les universitaires ceux qui
sont des spécialistes des totalitarismes
et l'allemagne lise l'allemand ont déjà
lu mein kampf le livre interdit donc ça
c'est pas vrai ça n'existe pas le
travail et même ce travail existent déjà
non % auront peu sage et des disques
déjà l'équivalent 10 ou 15 euros non
mais moi je n'ai pas quand le si vous
avec on apprend des milliers de choses
même moi qui connaît bien le sujet on
apprend des messieurs le suédois pour un
universités c'est vraiment je le dis
d'accord c'est renoncer un trésor un
trésor à 10 ans de travaux non mais
j'espère que le travail ne s'adresse pas
seulement aux fils de serge et béate
klarsfeld
il nous a tué dix éclairer là dessus le
débat et si c'est que si je prends votre
argument et je peux l'entendre
aujourd'hui bien racines qui se
développe faut lutter conte pour des
outils pédagogiques pour le faire je dis
que ce livre n'est pas l'outil
pédagogique en question c'est pas vrai
c'est lequel ou alors pour le prix le
prix le volume et ses îles et
réfléchissons à des outils beaucoup plus
efficace moi ce que je crains c'est
pousse à régler qui je prends pas les
affaires mais je vais vous dire pardon
je t'ai jamais terminé mon raisonnement
sécu doit y avoir elle malgré tout une
facilité est dit et c'est diffusé et il
y aura un effet malgré tout mais le
libra de pardon je suis
géraldine l'adil le livrer depuis 1979
où il est l'argent vous savez être
publiés en vous servez avec un
avertissement de huit pages j'ai compris
celles ci moi ce que je trouve c'est que
on tolère parfois une forme
d'antisémitisme mondain les gens qui ont
de l'argent
moi je m'étais mis en colère ya pas
longtemps contre il ya un écrivain qui
s'appelle louis ferdinand céline a écrit
des livres le mile au voyage au bout de
la nuit puis aussi des livres
dégueulasse antisémite chaussures et un
éditeur chez gallimard un grand éditeur
je les coûts soupçonne pas d'être
antisémite
quand même dernièrement a tenu à
rééditer ses livres moi je dis est alors
bien sûr on m'a dit c'est le livre chère
luxueux mais on tolère une forme les
gens qui ont de l'argent fait c'est les
emplois les moyens parce que soi-disant
les gens qui ont de l'argent et ils sont
moins bêtes que les gens du peuple et
ils sont plus immunisée contre les idées
antisémites et moi je n'aime pas cela et
je vais vous dire il y aura un effet
malgré tout pas chez tout le monde
mais un petit effet d'aubaine de
s'acheter dans une édition luxueuse de
lire des saloperies antisémites et moi
je ne vois pas de ça d'un bon oeil parce
que je trouve que c'est pas bien je vais
l'acheter mais ils peuvent déjà
l'acheter mais ce que c'est à dire
offrir l'accès avec la couverture du fâ
l'heure en plus cela kaunas et par une
ouverture des accords des éditions
souvent assez dégueulasse juste ils sont
pas très bien lisible de s'imprimer sur
son imprimante monsieur klarsfeld
s'imprimer à la maison sur une
imprimante mein kampf c'est pas la même
chose que d'avoir un joli livre relié
qui peuvent donc voilà un problème et je
pense qu'on peut mieux faire pour lutter
contre les totalitarismes alexis je
rejoins votre idée sur les 100 euros
est ce qu'il aurait pas été possible je
sais pas je vous pose la question de
faire une édition avec les annotations
critique qui soit équivalent lire à part
les universitaires moi qui m'intéresse
le livre d'abord il est ennuyeux si rien
de personnel il a il dit rien de
personnel sur lui-même
ce sont des sortes de darwinisme naturel
qu'il transpose lisible à la société
avec les races vouloir céder l'objet
sans même l'ouvrir personnes ils vont
gérer ses réserves donc même
ils marne moi qui connaît bien le sujet
qui m'intéresse c'est à dire c'est comme
c'est pas moi quelqu'un qui connaît bien
tintin et milou alors il est très
content d'avoir un truc sur tintin et
milou
bon c'est un peu la même chose je
connais bien l'histoire c'est à dire
chaque chose me rappelle quelque chose
que j'ai déjà lu et tout ça même moi
j'ai trouvé ça ennuyeux mais en tout par
son texte mais enrichissant par les gars
par les critiques
vous croyez pas que quelqu'un qui ne
connaît pas grand chose à la seconde
guerre mondiale va acheter ce livre pour
regarder l'allemand le livre est destiné
à quelqu'un qui est un universitaire un
professeur et qui ensuite popularisé ce
qu'il a lu les éclairés par les parlers
l'édition critique
valérie benaïm êtes d'accord avec arnaud
oui je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
les mois très je suis très honnête très
spontanément quand j'ai appris la
réédition en promenant mon premier
évidemment élan a été de dire mais c'est
pas possible on insulte la mémoire des
morts et des déportés et puis après je
me suis ravisé j'ai réfléchi je me suis
posé je me suis dit est-ce qu'on veut
est ce qu on veut effacer
c'est à dire ça n'a pas eu lieu on veut
pas voir on met la tête dans le sable et
on ne veut pas comprendre
relire éviter que ça revienne ou est-ce
qu'on veut se poser décrypter analyser
réfléchir moi je préfère cette deuxième
solution
si nous sommes ici pour nous donner bien
sa liste déjà qui à chaque année et
d'environ de livres universitaires et en
évidence une année c'est nous qui sommes
nés libres par ailleurs par agassa même
ce qu'il savait à quel point le fruit
défendu
c'est toujours plus beau mais là on est
alors de fonction en tant que témoin
alexis corbière mais le fruit défendu
il est plus défendu la mairie il est
plus défendu la table et on est plus
aisé d'aller sur le dark tête pour le
chauffer ce que je peux dire pour la
diriger et l'as aulnoye il est à noter
adhérer au moins il ya du regard des
explications dans les années je veux
dire une chose sans être trop ça sans
faire trop le malin il ya un débat chez
les historiens qui consiste à dire le
nazisme soit en l'expliquant fonction
des conditions de la défaite de la
première guerre mondiale de le but
chômage qui monte en allemagne de la
crise économique aussi de la volonté de
la part de s'il ya une poussée
révolutionnaire l'allemagne et il ya des
gens qui ont de l'argent qui donne de
l'argent à ces nazis pour casser la
figure aux syndicalistes pour empêcher
qu'ils aient des mouvements sociaux
c'est ça qui explique la montée du
nazisme ou alors on explique qu' un
livre diabolique qui expliquerait des
choses et on met au centre mein kampf
est selon moi on ne comprend pas le
nazisme en raison d'un livre
non mais c'est
et donc j'ai un désaccord avec le titre
historiciser le mal
mais cette charge morale ne veut rien
dire c'est pas le mal comme si c'était
le diable c'est parmi d'autres
historique et politique jamais demander
si la montée l'examen de l'éclair au
centrisme c'est à dire quoi en fait
c'est tout sur la figure de mein kampf
et sur la figure 2 mais il se trouve que
néanmoins qu'on le veuille ou non ces
halles cc la théorisation de ce nom de
ses parts exactement sympa même si vous
n'avez pas comment l'assureur n'est pas
présente dans mein kampf des cartes et
les allemands tous des juifs à redon il
ya dans mein kampf une volonté de
terminer de mettre les juifs atwater dur
à expliquer il ya des fois où il dit si
on avait mis quelques milliers de juifs
sous les gaz de la seconde les gaz qui
était dans les tranchées et bien
l'allemagne l'allemagne aura gagné aura
gagné la première guerre guerre mondiale
donc et il y avait aussi la volonté de
tuer dès la naissance les les enfants
qui ne sont la vie ne valait pas la
peine d'être vécue et c est très anti
rallye c'est d'ailleurs le programme a
été d'ailleurs le programme ce qui
s'appelait le programme t4 pour thiers
garden chômage 4 a été décidé cette
opération contre les mêmes malades
mentaux et bien elle a précédé la mise à
mort la mort mise à mort des juifs et on
peut la deviner cette volonté de mise à
mort des juifs déjà dans mein kampf
anthony car il est arrivé
quelqu'un qui était vagabond quelqu'un
qui dans tout le monde se moquait eh
bien il est arrivé en temps de crise par
sa démagogie par son talent de tribun à
prendre le pouvoir dans une allemagne en
crise et c'est pour ça que je dis aux
gens méfiez-vous des démagogues à la
fois des démagogues d'extrême droite et
des démagogues d'extra mais où sont les
cris surtout ami parce qu'il suffit que
c'est surtout le chômage sont là
débattre contre les crises mais vous
aussi se méfier des démagogues qui
utilisent et crise pour prendre le
pouvoir
dès qu un démagogue arrive au pouvoir
qui soit d'extrême droite ou des temps
et d'extrême gauche
il n'y a pas d'exode quand quelqu'un
d'extrême droite ou d'extrême gauche
avec un démagogue de droite votent pour
ou contre ce qu'on vous dit
voici d'ailleurs le centre on sait très
bien est ce que c'est le centre droit le
centre gauche mais on sait très bien
aussi ce qu'est l'extrême droite et ce
qu'est l'extrême non mais on n'est pas
moi moi je veux pas polémiquer vous mais
vous êtes un peu dur mais vous vous êtes
aussi militant politique par ailleurs
vous êtes de moi je suis ou du centre
droit ou du centre gauche selon les amis
je vous l ai lu canada pour osi amical
alors d'aller collard sa musique extrême
droite
maintenant on était macro aux dernières
élections président semble bon et je
veux très très long mais revenons à la
déception je voterais pour le candidat
le mieux placé pour faire barrage ou au
candidat d'extrême droite au candidat
d'extrême gauche pour l'instant c'est le
candidat d'extrême d'extraits de
journaux dallest c'est la même chose
pour vous madame le pen et mélenchon
en tous les cas si on se retourne sur
l'histoire du 20e siècle
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche ont
apporté mon âge je pose une question
pour vous c'est la même chose mélenchon
à l'open les démagogues ils sont les
mêmes mais c'est la magie de la même
donc non vie où les idées de jean luc
mélenchon et celle d'homme de l'extrême
droite c'est la même chose et vous êtes
un beau lutter contre les menaces et que
ceux qui sont contre le racisme et ceux
qui sont pour c'est la même chose
madame madame le pen n'est pas hitler
monsieur mélenchon n'est pas staline
mais il ya une dynamique dans les partis
extrémistes qui amène vous choisirez pas
si de magna un second tour mélenchon le
pen vous choisissez je veux lui je m'en
vais je ne reste pas en francs et c'est
bien votre bouquin à 100 euros c'est
utile contre l'extrême je ne sais même
pas celui qui est contre le racisme et
pour l'égalité entre les jambes c'est la
même chose on s'en souvient en transe
amitié
cet épisode de pollution
géraldine redit que vous venez de nom
mais parfois la france insoumise et un
peu ambigu sur l'antisémitisme et paraît
parfois vous êtes madame ben je sais pas
moi non mais donnez moi un exemple parce
que moi je pense aux que vous nous dire
que les nations non dimanche accepte
fois l'antisémitisme fois il ya des
ambiguïtés dans madame ce n'est pas vrai
débat juridique si c'est vrai ne
m'habite et plus jamais syrie par ne
m'invitez pas avec ça moi je suis pas
venu non mais je voulais dire sérieux en
plein jeu c'est comme si je vais pas
vous non mais je comprends ce que
voulait venir mais acceptez vous prenez
ce que j'ai alors dit de moi sur quoi ce
je suis en vie même parfois non j'ai pas
dis vous j'imagine sur le parti qui
madame turquie mais damas d'avoir
exemple qui les oppose sur quoi je sais
pas sur quoi c'est grave de dire ça je
trouve que parfois il y à une mode grave
de dire écoutez tant pis je le dis de
les trouver le pardon et j'éprouve je
vous apporterai mes pièces à conviction
là pour une fois vous imaginez ce que
vous dites mais si je disais une
méchanceté sur monsieur klarsfeld
castaldi je veux dire c'est trouver le
ces infâmes on joue pas avec
l'antisémitisme merde moi j'ai région
tronchon excusez moi madame vous pouvez
nous reprocher des choses mais pas ça
moi je n'accepte pas ou alors je vis ici
dit si vous pensez ça ne m'était plus
jamais si la merde avec ça vous savez
alexis palisson lui de s'expliquer
l'ensemble avait un excellent berlin à
plusieurs reprises certains des membres
de votre parti on les a a minima
soupçonnés d' ambiguïté oui mais
seulement d'origine au saumon ambiguïté
il est ignoble des problèmes on en parle
il est possible qu'il y ait des gens qui
étaient à la france a su je ne sais pas
mais il serait une étape immédiatement
exclu et vous aurez raison de nous les
pointer le rappel est le mien ambiguïté
on les rudes et une seconde masqué après
quand il ya eu les événements assez à
sarcelles après c'était en 2014 après la
guerre entre israël et le hamas mais eu
les événements à sarcelles ou des
maisons des immeubles ont été brûlées
vous en souvenez 1 est bien mais
jean-luc mélenchon a fait un discours
que j'ai écoutés et que j'ai retranscrit
et où ils 17 sont celles eu l'effet de
quelques énergumènes quelques exergue
humaine et la communauté qui est
agressive c'est la communauté juive
c'est pas vrai jeu écoutez moi je ne
mens jamais je mangerai jeu
mais je vous promets à paris si vous
voulez parier on peut parier
j'ai le discours je vous le tient je
vous le donnerai vous le discours
m'avait extrêmement choquée le discours
était we are all antisémite je dois leur
dire c'est en tous les cas l'extrême
gauche quand elle arrive le pouvoir elle
devient nécessairement antisémite
en général c'est le cas avec sa droite
en votant éventuellement mélenchon ou
des gens qui sont eux même si des plus
qu'avant on ne s'éloigne du sujet même
si vous placez au pardon c'est sûr que
ça me suggéra lexsi que je connais bien
si elle est comme il est absolu bien si
l examen avait été antisémite
la raison et voilà c'est quelqu'un voilà
en tout cas même jean luc mélenchon et
de mes amis
une accusation non mais visait une
accusation est grave si elle est vraie
discuter pour mes amis
oui à 63% non à 37% ils savent que ça
coûte sa propre rôle et 60% pour les
enseignants oui mais non mais n'a pas
que des enseignants qui nous regardent
non mais c'est pour les universitaires
et les traits l'ouvragé envoyé
gratuitement dans des bibliothèques
hochet